marvel readers have been familiar with
venom for decades but the half alien
anti-hero is only just now making his
standalone big screen debut from who's
playing who to the comics you need to
brush up on
here's everything you need to know
before you see venom
a symbiote story also known as the
klyntars the symbiotes are a race of
extraterrestrial fully sentient
parasites
they live by cocooning living organisms
and feeding off their adrenaline
sucking hosts dry before leaving them
for dead the venom symbiote is unique in
its
species for desiring long-lasting bonds
over quick kills
a trait which makes it an outcast making
its first appearance in a string of 1984
comics
the venom symbiote originally attached
itself to peter parker
in the form of a black spider-man suit
while peter initially enjoyed the
benefits of the symbiote he worked to
rid himself of it after he discovered
its villainous nature
eventually driving it away by exploiting
its weakness to loud sounds
a new host the best known human half of
venom is eddie brock
played by tom hardy in the 2018 film
created by david michelani and todd
mcfarland
the character made its first
full-fledged appearance in a 1988 issue
of amazing spider-man
in the comics brock is a once respected
reporter who lost his job as an indirect
result of spider-man's crime fighting
specifically he's fired after a
high-profile story about a serial
killer's true identity is discredited
after spider-man nabs the real culprit
furious in seeking guidance
the catholic brock takes refuge in a
church the same church whose loud bells
peter successfully used to separate from
the symbiote after they encounter each
other brock and the symbiote bond over a
shared hatred of spider-man
and venom as we know him is born
existing outside of the marvel cinematic
universe the venom movie
significantly tweaks brock's original
story removing the peter parker element
and setting the action entirely in
brock's home city of san francisco
in the movie venom bonds with brock
without ever encountering peter parker
as you can tell from the lack of white
spider markings on the movie venom suit
adapting the source while the venom
movie is an original story
it's based on two distinct marvel comic
arcs the first
1993's lethal protector is a six-issue
story that sees spider-man and venom
arranging a truce with the latter
agreeing to leave new york for san
francisco
venom takes up a role as a bay area
anti-hero eventually teaming up with
spider-man again to fend off five new
villainous symbiotes
the second chunk of source material is
1995's planet of the symbiotes a
five-issue arc which also follows venom
and his allies
as they work to stop a worldwide
symbiote invasion combine the two
together and you get the movie's story
of a brutal west coast superhero
protecting san francisco from his
violent fellow aliens
the life foundation in the comics the
shady organization of survivalists
called the life foundation
was formed during the cold war by people
who believed that the world was headed
for a nuclear holocaust
to ensure the survival of civilized life
on earth the foundation built a massive
fallout shelter for survivors
or at least those wealthy enough to buy
themselves a space
to protect the shelter in its
inhabitants the life foundation
kidnapped venom and used them to create
five new symbiotes agony phage lasher
scream and riot all of which get bonded
to life foundation employees
reportedly the big bad and venom will be
the formidable riot
latching himself primarily under riz
ahmed's character life foundation boss
carlton drake dreams of carnage
venom's most famous symbiote nemesis is
carnage an
unhinged offshoot of venom that latches
onto the psychotic killer cletus cassidy
though sony has tried to keep his
involvement a secret
cassidy is reportedly being played in
the film by woody harrelson
though that doesn't necessarily mean
that carnage himself is showing up
speaking to collider harrelson said his
appearance in venom is more of a setup
for the future while the actor did not
confirm he was playing cassidy
he hinted at the sequel tease nature of
his role saying i'm in a little fraction
of this movie but i'll be in the next
one you know
she venom michelle williams stars in
venom is anne wayne who in the comics is
a hot shot lawyer and eddie brock's
ex-wife
the movie makes tweaks to their
relationship making her brock's current
girlfriend as opposed to his ex
much like cletus cassidy anne is another
character with some secret significance
in the comics wayne becomes the
character she venom gaining the powers
of the symbiote after brock allows the
two to bond
williams has already made it clear that
the movie anne will be no pushover but
will she really transform into she venom
probably not in this one more likely
she's in the movie as a seed of what
could come
if venom does well enough to warrant its
own sequels you can bet we'll see more
famous symbiotes taking turns in the
spotlight